foreign
[Music]
oh my God I'm dead you're not dead you
just been separated from your physical
form
no idea you should not be able to do
that it feels amazing
that might be one of the coolest things
that's ever happened to me but don't
ever do that again
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
true
what is this place the mirror Dimension
where I'm in control
strange stop can we please just talk
about this Parker don't you realize that
in the Multiverse there are an infinite
number of people who know Peter Parker
is Spider-Man and if that spell gets
loose they're all coming here look I
know I get it but we can't just send
them home to die it's their faith
you can't change that any more than you
could change who they are but what if we
could what if we could change their fate
hello what are you doing
oh
give me your back
wait a minute is that an archimedian
spiral the mirror Dimension is just
geometry you're great at geometry you
could do geometry
Square the radius divide by pie clock
punch along the curve over Parker
I'll come pick you up when it's done
math don't do this
ow I'm sorry sir but
[Music]